one of the things that Derek did
recently him and Matt does Fitness yeah
because last time that we spoke was
about two and a half years ago
a couple of miles in that direction I
think and we were talking then and all
of the like is he natural accusations
that have followed you since we were in
uni basically like 15 years ago
and I think that one of the concerns
that you'd had then was well
no matter what test you do there is
always going to be somebody that says
it's insufficient it's not enough it's
blah blah blah and I think Matt had that
problem too Matt went to Derek and said
design me the most rigorous randomized
testing protocol in the world is that
something that yes
I've emailed Derek and I've WhatsApp
Derek two months ago right no reply
you're kidding me yeah you're kidding
I'll show you after this because I spoke
to obviously I've seen this all
happening I've been watching the videos
I speak to Matt he's like one of my best
friends and
um
Matt was telling me because I asked for
his number Matt was saying
uh just be aware it's a massive ball
like
on both ends because he has to be
available to do all these random tests
he's got to pay for it but then Derek
has to do so much organization
you know he's getting things set up in a
country which he doesn't live in and the
whole process he can't just do all these
random tests in a week or two weeks it
has to be over a exciting a five-month
period yeah so
um he got on that first did everything
he could have possibly done and proved
that he's not taking anything so I saw
the announcement of Matt's thing I never
actually saw the results did he get yes
leaner and stronger and well the results
I think because it was all messed up
because he tore his Achilles
like before the testing started playing
football
so he's I don't know what he's trying to
prove that he could still maintain his
lifts or something so I think he was
able to bring it back but he was getting
tested throughout and there was no funky
stuff happening okay but it was
interesting because he's making these
videos and
proving that it's natural and then
there's still people who are like
no I don't believe you they're not happy
so why did you if that's the case why
would you message Derek if Matt's gone
through the most rigorous testing
protocol available to man and that's
still not sufficient for some people
because I think there's there's
literally nothing more you can do
and if anybody is going to oversee any
kind of testing I would want Derek to do
it because I'd pick up the phone I know
I'll ring him I'll ring him once we're
finished up I was texting him this
morning I've got the email and WhatsApp
but I'm not gonna pester him to because
I imagine how busy he is to give him his
due that man is drowning in emails 24 7.
yeah there was a period of
I'll ask him if I can put this into the
podcast I'm sure he won't have a problem
with it but we can cut it if need to be
uh after he released the liver King
video which was you know this big
Crescendo and then he does Rogan then he
does me then he does Zach uh what's that
then he does uh like a comedy podcast
and then maybe just one more and he was
like dude I'm I have six months of
unanswered emails to deal with because
all he'd been doing was grinding
creating content then build up to this
kind of big Crescendo maximum thing and
then all he's like what's he released
like three videos maybe since
November December time because he's
super busy this is one of the things
that I don't know people don't
really see the
pain that goes into creating content
like that
or even for you it's so effortful to
make a [__] Vlog yeah the vlog's
along dude it is so painful and
it looks like a a beautiful life the
number one uh desired job amongst
American children is influencer yeah now
and I would imagine that you know
YouTuber would probably get folded into
that
there are some amazing parts of the job
but there are some bits that absolutely
suck if you're sat with your editor the
night before it needs to be uploaded
looking at the edit unhappy with
something giving him amends on frame dot
IO or whatever it is that you're using
yeah
it's not that much fun and I think that
what you're seeing with Derek is you
know the fall off on you but it's the
same with me I used to have this really
strict schedule where I would have to
post a certain time on a certain day and
I would literally be pulling my hair out
just to make sure that everything was
perfect everything was filmed and when I
wasn't you know maybe two hours were
left before the upload and it wasn't
ready I would be so stressed out and
then I just thought it's not even worth
it just remove the schedule
it's posted when it's ready yeah post it
a day later two days later what do you
think this is an interesting thing
especially given that you've been in the
YouTube scene for a very long time since
before I think before Derek was on
YouTube although he has been on for a
long time talking about non-fitness
content
do you think that he has been
one of the bigger biggest influences in
kind of shaping Fitness YouTube over the
last few years what do you think is sort
of I think so in terms of Education
definitely because he's he's like a
freaking encyclopedia he knows so much
so he's definitely
he's definitely had a positive impact
I don't know anyone else who's I think
there's a few other people now who are
pretty clued up when it comes to Jeff
nepard maybe yes and he puts a hell of a
lot of work into his videos yeah there's
another guy he puts the I've got his
name he puts all these um
like uh bands on his muscles okay so it
can pick up the twitching of the fibers
and he does all these exercises oh and
there's a Ryan Ryan something okay well
and he and that will determine how much
yeah so muscle activation yeah muscle
activation doing different exercises
I've never seen it before and I watched
a few of his videos and he's he's very
uh charismatic mathematic and staining
that's cool yeah I so
what would you the trend when you
started YouTube uh you know what I I
think I was I was lucky because I was
early yes I would agree you know that
Rob lips it like Harrison twins kind of
era-ish I think was a
you know it was a golden era for like
bro content Vlogs lifestyle lifting
to me now and I'm outside of that
uh whatever like cohort of delivery on
YouTube in any case
but to me it it really feels like the
um
evidence-based you know sort of more
scientific approach to education I'm
sure that there still are big lifestyle
channels out there but like I don't see
your Jeff's sides of the world your
David laids of the world like they don't
that that style seems to have dropped
away and even your stuff seems to be
leaning increasingly towards education
even outside of Fitness is that but I
feel like that is what YouTube is
becoming it's becoming more of a
platform for education
like you said there is there there is
always going to be room for those uh
vloggers and lifestyle
people like Jesse James he's smashing it
at the moment yeah there's only very few
people who can do that
and
maybe this I feel like it's one of those
things where people have seen everything
true it's hard to reinvent unique what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]